if I were to ask you the question what
is a Gorgon it's likely that many of you
would point towards the most famous
example that you can think of Medusa and
although you may be correct because
Medusa was in fact a Gorgon
it's a question that is far more
difficult to answer in the image of the
Gorgon that we paint today has been so
much skewed and distorted by the media
we consume to the point where it barely
even resembles the original stories of
Gorgons with in Greek mythology itself
if I were to show you this rough image
or outline it's very likely that most of
you would still be able to tell me that
what you see is either Medusa or a
Gorgon but if I then show you this image
I'd hazard a guess that only a few would
identify what they see as a Gorgon so
how did we go from one to the other and
the answer itself is quite simple or the
mainstream media and Hollywood Medusa
has always been a popular Greek tale but
in 1981 with the release of the original
Clash of the Titans movie the image of
Medusa as a snake was well received by
most audiences and thus the trend began
and the user followed many of the movies
TV shows and artwork depicting Medusa
and her fellow Gorgons showed them as
snake haired women of the body of a
snake
we even see this in the God of War
franchise which depicts Medusa and her
sisters in the exact same way this means
that those who have learnt about Greek
mythology through these varying forms of
media would have already really known
this one particular image but why did
this change happen in the first place I
think the majority of this change can be
attributed to fear and the movie
industry's need to create a truly
terrifying monster if you already have a
woman of a head of hair made from snakes
it's a fairly natural transition to then
remove more for human aspects and
qualities in this scenario that would
involve removing her legs and replacing
them with the body of a snake this not
only allows her to move in a different
and almost more sinister manner but it
also transforms her from a woman of a
physical abnormality into a literal
monster I do honestly believe that the
modern images of Gorgons are terrifying
in their own way because they seem far
less human than they did before but it's
an interesting example of how myth can
change so drastically in a short period
of time now that we've gone over the
modern depiction of a Gorgon we can
discuss how they appeared in classical
Greek mythology so I guess the best
place to start here would be with the
most famous examples we have Medusa and
her two sisters steno and Uriah
the two sisters are often described as
being born immortal but being extremely
ugly Medusa on the other hand is
described as being born human and
possessing a great deal of beauty but
this really wasn't the case all three
sisters were born Gorgon and this whole
sentiment of Medusa been somewhat
attractive didn't really manifest until
around 490 BC when the Greek poet
Pinder's described her as fair cheek to
Medusa and this was later echoed in the
work of the Roman poet Ovid who
popularized the idea that Medusa was
once a beautiful maiden turned into a
Goldman by the goddess Athena originally
the Gorgons were described as three
powerful winged demons with swine light
tusks talons for feet and iconic head of
hair made from snakes and sometimes even
a short stubbly beard the Goldman's
appearance is very reminiscent of the
harpies in the arenas who existed long
before and who were described as seven
snakes intertwined in their body around
their waist and their arms and most
importantly even within their hair it
wasn't too uncommon for Gorgons to be
described as having an extreme hate for
men and I know this coupled with the
description I've just given you makes
him sound and awfully look like
modern-day feminists but I assure you
Gorgons are far more interesting the
ancient Greeks saw the Gorgon sisters as
terrifying creatures with the word
Gorgas meaning grim and dreadful but
where exactly did these winged demons
come from much like the origins of many
creatures and monsters within Greek
mythology there is always some debate as
to where they came from and the Gorgons
are no different in this regard the most
common explanation being that they were
the children of forces and seto two
ancient primordial sea deities with the
origins of the wide sea tone mean in sea
monster and the to date he's been known
for bearing numerous monstrous children
the fact they were considered the
parents of the Gorgons is no real
surprise one of the more interesting
origin stories regarding the Gorgon
states that there were the children of
forces and Gorgo the daughter of Helios
she was an ancient Gorgon slain by Zeus
at the very start of the Titan war
similar in appearance to Gorgo many
considered the true father of Medusa and
the gobiins to have been the elder
Gorgon the primal Gorgon who appeared as
a bearded man or woman with both male
and female attributes making it's true
gender quite difficult to determine we
don't know much about the primal Gorgon
but the idea that Medusa and her sisters
will not the first goal is to exist is
one that we see a fair few times there
have been some historians who over the
years claimed that these stories of
women who appear in the shape of
serpents may have once originated from
northern Africa particularly in the
region of Libya which is also said to be
the home of the queen turned monster
Lamia and of course the collective
Lambie eye a group of creatures whose
appearance resembles the modern-day half
woman half snake depiction of a Gorgon
so what we consider to be a Gorgon today
is most likely closer in appearance to
Lamia than the Gorgons of Greek
mythology for those wanting to learn
more about the backstory of Medusa
sisters steno and geraldi sadly there
isn't a whole lot that we know about
them steena for the most part is
considered to be the eldest of the three
sisters with her name meaning strong and
forceful
she's described as having red snakes
that sit atop her head which is the only
rule defining characteristic that sets
her apart in terms of appearance from
her sisters the only real story that she
features in is that of Perseus and
Medusa where she attempts to avenge her
sister after she'd been slain but thanks
to the cap of invisibility given to
Perseus by Hades
she's largely unsuccessful in this task
Yali whose name means far roaming was
the second born and has no real defining
physical features but she was known for
her face and bellowing cries that could
incapacitate a grown man most noticeably
heard during the death of her sister
Medusa of course features in numerous
stories and is what many considered to
be the queen of the Gorgons and of the
origins of her name meaning to protect
and to rule over
Queen is exactly what many believed her
name to mean with that being said it's
fairly obvious that Medusa is unique to
her sisters and if we go by Ovid
interpretation and those that later
followed she was born human and assumed
the role of priestess to Athena
it was only later in her life that she
was transformed into a Gorgon and
depending on which interpretation you've
read this was seen as either a gift or a
curse it was only after Athena's
transformation that Medusa resembled her
sisters and possessed the same
petrifying gaze a gaze that would be
just as potent even when she was slain
as it was used by Perseus to save
Andromeda from being sacrificed by
turning the giant sea monster Cetus into
stone there is even a story of a
disagreement between Perseus and the
Titan atlas which results in a Titan
being turned into stone
with the use of Medusa's head once again
if the story of Medusa before she became
a Gorgon is something you'd be
interested in it is one of the six
stories that will be featured in our
book so keep an eye out for that one
when Homer discusses the Gorgon he does
so as a singular entity but in the work
that followed by Hesiod we see this
expanded to a trio of sisters if we go
as far back as possible
the earliest accounts of Gorgons are as
sworn protectors of the Oracles now
these protectors are never really
described as Gorgons more so a Serpent's
but the image of the Gorgon was often
associated with the Temple of the Oracle
garden the entrance from evils that wish
to enter we've discussed some of the
possible origins and how the Gorgons
have gone through a visual
transformation but we've yet to discuss
the powers associated with a Gorgon the
Gorgons village was said to be so
horrifying that it would turn the
beholder into stone the idea of
petrification or turning someone or
something into stone is quite common in
most myth and folklore ranging from
legends of the basilisk in the
cockatrice to the black elves of Norse
mythology and of course Medusa and her
sisters there are those such as Jane
Ellen Harrison a scholar known for her
studies of Greek myth and religion we
believe that Medusa's true power only
manifested itself after she had been
killed
although Hama never really mentioned the
Medusa by name he does make some
reference to her in the Odyssey when he
says lest for my Darin Persephone the
dread from Hades should send up an awful
monsters grizzly head
Harrison translated what Homer said to
mean that the Gorgon was made out of
terror not terror out of the Gorgon in
the several times Homer mentions the
Gorgon he only describes the head and
Harrison this time states that Medusa is
nothing more than a head nothing more
than a mosque with a body later appended
Medusa one alive was extremely feared
she brought terror and suffering but in
her death her head was associated with
protection and healing in ancient Greece
a special amulet was created of the face
of a Gorgon name the gorgonian and this
was used to ward away harmful intentions
evil influences and misfortune the head
of a Gorgon was even placed on Athena's
shield the aigis and both Athena and
Zeus were said to have worn the
protective amulet before the work of
Pinder's the gorgonian whether it
appeared on pendants amulets or the
shields of warriors was always depicted
as rather ugly
large tusks are protruding tongue and a
stare that challenged anyone who would
dare to gaze upon it after the 5th
century BC the change in attitudes
towards a Gorgons appearance manifested
itself in the gorgonian these shields
vases and pendants showing Gorgons
became less grotesque they lost their
tusks and the snakes became more of a
hairstyle than a chaotic mess
the Medusa Rondo Nene is perhaps the
most iconic piece to mark this
transitional period as here we see a
Gorgon that has been modeled in the
guise of a beautiful woman rather than a
repulsive creature I do find it quite
interesting that the Gorgons and Medusa
in particular have gone from ugly
monsters to beautiful women and now they
sit somewhere oddly enough in the Middle
where we can tell that they're a monster
but there is still this kind of
seductive sex appeal overall it's quite
difficult to really explain the role
that the Gorgons played in actual Greek
mythology the earliest accounts that are
extremely vague described them as the
protectors of the Oracles and this is
something that we do see later with
protective amulets and trinkets have in
the head of a Gorgon on them we know
that the word Gorgon would instill
terror and fear but much like the other
demonic female figures who are charged
with protection and enforcing the law
the harpies and the arrhenius the
Gorgons are never really described as
being evil this is a notion later
perpetuated by movies and stories who
portrayed Medusa as a villain which is
around the same time the image [ __ ]
Gorgon transformed from a woman who
shaped still resembled a human to a
seductress of the lower half of a snake
the Gorgons themselves may not have
appeared in dozens of stories but they
definitely have more of a cultural
meaning and relevance behind them with
their image almost acting like a
good-luck charm which in itself is quite
odd to consider and how monstrous they
look but when you really think about it
what better way to ward off evil than
with something just as terrifying I can
only hope that this video has been
informative and enjoyable for most of
you and if it has and you'd like to
leave the video alike that would be
greatly appreciated if you have any
thoughts on Al Gore wins that you'd like
to share with me then please do so in
the comments below or perhaps you just
like to tell me how often the new intro
is regardless I look forward to hearing
from you as always I've been your host
mythology in fiction explained
you
you